il motore questo perché se questo
silenzio no
ciao a tutti e notizia lite st rossi e
stoner interno
oggi nuovo live a grandi marchi è che
questo è l'ultimo video non è stato
molto fortunato con queste cose calate
che tantissimi d'attacco che se lo
chiedete di fare tre colori di clay
challenge senso di fare un bel mix di
colori e faremo tre colori di flake i
tre colori coloranti in cui ci sono
anche glitter metallizzati e più tre
colori di blister troppo curioso di
vedere come sia allo zen dic i colori
syrah provate a dominare già nei
commenti
lo ritieni che colori per digitare lo
divido marrone il suo grigio e il
marrone che mirka rosa rosa tutti certo
la più pronta profondo come invece come
steccati esca blu oppure reale oppure
già lester bird bird però se avremo la
maledizione del verde vitale e quella
del grigio e del marrone
lasciate un bel haj che se volete
attrezza l'en plein consigliate sicure
nei commenti che altre cialente che
facciamo soprattutto quelle col cibo che
a me piacciono tanto nei loro collegi
verificava di prese di bloccarne
d'italia che allora nel primo turno
impegneremo con i glitter passo mi
capite nei bitter
certi valori rossi rosi g rossi e blu
per lei ha finalmente piccolo quindi
abbiamo visto che allora io vado bene
vitale va a picchiarli si deve portare
sempre più di quanto non c'è che dire
allora cleaning è stato qua deve cercare
le eccezioni io ti tengo la mano si ma
non far toccare tutto anzi non fai
davvero fortuna 0 che bene
come ho fatto ho fatto già coperto near
chiaro utilizzati in questi ultimi sono
più fortunata noleggia la prima aspetta
come bene un passato di carta ma questa
non è una canzone questo non la dà la
sveglia la mattina bene beh beh baciare
degradano la sveglia la mattina che ti
vogliono bene
beli meteo linea tutti vi vedete bene
anche voi
ok allora sono qua d'aiuto questi temi
ha tutto sia sul piano della lotta
faccia dei malware sono bianca e il
dritto il bianco quello con la bianca
cammello
sicuramente si vedrà come l'inter da
tempo la cosa che la casa d'aste però
sono bianco perlato quindi forse si
vedranno un po di riflessi ma che stai
dicendo
immagina se ti capita beate avviato più
con la bio la notte bianca e pubblico in
piazza è tutto dialetti
[Musica]
ecco fa i miei glitter gialli andiamo a
metterli dalla nostra collo
no
ma vediamo speriamo che si vedano bene
abbiamo fatto l'aiuto lato
sa com'è se poi con il colorante e con
il play sono troppo curiosa che belli
brillano anche se la con la bianca si
vedono comunque mi piacciono già un
tacco mettiamo un po il tuo come diventa
riveliamo l'inter bianchi stesso tempo
presa perché non ho mai fatto una live
con i glitter bianchi che sono molto
luminosi magari di qualche effetto lo fa
mestiere fa un bianco bernato bastano
quattro etti
dobbiamo girare adesso dai suoi sono
carini sonologi troppo adesso che lo
giri tutto rimane più niente
si vedono vediamo adesso il secondo
round che colorante si capito sei pronto
nota
vitale fatto di strade e milito italiana
dagli ma un fatto allora tre secondo
rambo dobbiamo pescare il colorante
e poi dobbiamo stare molto attenti
perché il colorante avrebbe rovinarlo a
renderlo benissimo nel tuo campo libera
perché tu no tu stai portando fortuna
questo luogo
questi ultimi a rischio il rischio
rischio fischio tutti casi che campo
dalle cantate da questi sono i fatti di
vedere quali settima adesso devo
dimettere tutti i diritti perché le
ducati alla disfatta e allora speciali
da allora questi quasi quale sceglie
aiuta
non parte lombardi un motore questo
perché se questo silenzio no adesso al
centro se si ha un posto veramente
previste repliche
ma lo sa che apporta viggiù se anche non
è sconti non commentiamo e frank è
famosa non l'ho messo al centro quindi
lasciato tu mi vuoi dire un richiamo
proprio non capisco ora qualsiasi cli mi
capita si starà male iniziata col verde
nei commenti che lo sapete detto che
questo in realtà phone and ferb mousse
perché io lo vedo perde ma molti sono
gestito nei commenti di questo bando
toccherebbe acqua tipo poiché colore
vedete perché non elettriche aumenti se
rimangono piccolo ribery anzi spero che
per chi morgan con ora canta una canzone
di cartoni animati
ma cosa si provi anno aspetto 3 vicino
un po sono tardivi ok sono tutti
volontari
no aspetta
si no
qua mi chiamo il mio verde smeraldo cosa
è però i per me mamma perché ogni volta
che apre bocca di macchina ma anche di
palo
la maledizione del verde ha deciso di
espandersi ora cerco di toglierlo e
ancora peggio va allora faccia così
buffa cioè finirà prima il colorante
verde di tutti è quello che mi capita
sempre
vediamo forse diluito col bianco il
colore meno forte certo come no guarda
c'è questo e proprio belli come fatti a
vedere un altro colore verde turchese
sarei un po chiuso della morte si sta
chiarendo un po però vedi ma adesso si è
schiarito proverbio sembra un po verde
acqua sembra un pozzo destino verde
acqua e scrivete nei commenti che colore
è questo almeno si schierino un po
prossimo sempre perdonino però un po
verde acqua film e mi posso mettere il
giallo fosforescente evidenziatore ecco
che adesso andiamo a girare così glitter
bianchi per la di forza prendere un
pochettino più di colore perché ti che
abito marrone non si sta parlando di
solito preferito il giallo canarino
non uno di più meglio adesso che ti
capito che lei prenderà tutti
soprattutto una barone sono bellissimo
speriamo di no ma che riesce già uno
diventa avuto gia moltissimo
allora terzo e ultimo turno questo è il
turno decisivo che i colori ma non lo so
cosa si sta bene con questo verde forse
vero noi blue book mieko il blu o il
giallo il rosso blu
quello che spero che non riesca in
assoluto del marrone perché trasforma
tutto in cassetta ma anche un errore
anche il bianco abbiamo perso
[Musica]
te lo dico anche tu poi non lo metto in
meno male pure io non ho mai criticato
dalla mischia
ok bene no dove divertirvi un pochettino
no allora li ho messi tutti spesi a
quindi non sono in piedi
ok perché in istituti stessi perché
faccio come voglio
la casa mi trasmette allora ciao ciao
allora partono da coli e arrivano qui
capita mi devo far guidare da no sono mi
arriva il verde mi devo far guidare da
devo andare a casa dai brand a credere
che tra
[Musica]
però io pensavo dai all'altro non avrà
letto niente c'entra se volevi giallo
soli al centro la regia di chi sta come
uscirà il mio perde più nero ok sono
tutti qua qua
sì questo è l'ultimo dipende se può
essere il primo e l'ultimo quindi sono
qua
sì proprio quello che romanelli
[Musica]
allora dobbiamo attivare lo slime poi
una punta cattivo ve lo facciamo vedere
prima senza che lei è qui andiamo a dire
la play assieme a voi
prandi santissimo 32 dura da quasi live
alla fine il colore il sito super carino
perché è una porta di verde acqua
comunque un verde molto chiara bertè
mente potrebbe parlare un'effettiva
vediamo chi è l'ultimo che arriva
comunque la stessa e fighissima nobel
paul king l'unica cosa è che ora
dobbiamo andare ad aggiungere ci credo
va bene vitale ha perso il pezzo della
paletta dello slide vabbè comunque
adesso andiamo ad aggiungere il clero
mette un pò mitica tappa
vediamo un po più rilassante mischia
comunque sembra carbone questo clay nero
e lo abbiamo visto qualche colore di
verserà barra leggings uniamo magari
bebè tiene se teniamo
[Applauso]
che strano che è sporco la terra e le
sfumature no ad avvicinare con lo slang
linee al mio anche il mio è tutto del
capo mai opportuna dopo che già il clay
e blu giallo e blu non va verde oddio
mai diventato nero non ci crede e io
lavoravo bianco supera la canzone
minardo gatto nero
volevo volevo
bianco o bianco o nero come è mio
guardate un po è diventato nerissimo
incredibile c'è una sorta di grigio
scuro scuro non me l'aspettavo proprio
che cambiano di tutto il colore in cui
l'inter dorati eccolo qua non è male dai
anche se il colore è un po particolare
però non ribalti che ha una bellezza e
assistente katherine e vedere che molto
chiaro ed è un po appiccicoso e giallino
non so se si vede giallino tipo di crema
di limone una cremolino ora però
lasciato apposta pochettino più più
morbido e niente le super estendibile
allungabile vedete è troppo morbido
infatti lisi attaccatutto alle mani del
disastro fino adesso però dai almeno il
colore bello schema rumori wow che
rumori e adesso siamo pronti ad
aggiungere che ce la faccio ad
aggiungere il clay blu che bello
mediante proprio curiosa di dove quel e
cosetta nera league ed è uscita non può
diventare via perché molto delicato
tonelli è molto delicato questo
giornalismo e adesso cominciamo a
mischiare è incastrato da ieri notte si
sta già trasformando in blu blu blu blu
e blu mille bolle blu ne guarda te lo
faccio vedere perso un tempo subito che
attività legate stupendo vediamoli uno a
fianco all'altro ma questo più piccole
con progresso e mirabella league fra il
mio scurissimo vediamo un po come
consistenza morbida che fortuna che
diventa lui non è stata una bruttura
duro e booking per 1900 dato del rumore
allora votate non sa quale ho vinto io
se ha vinto vitale
marco allora devi andare lì quello sla
in campo ne posso farvi vedere questo
bando si fermerà gli altri video
cliccate cosa che proprie vite e buona